during new york fashion week british
label tetum jones presented its
collection at the finals for the
international walmart prize in keeping
with the rules of the competition for
up-and-coming fashion designers
everything on show was made from
australian merino wool it was romantic
and at the same time very pragmatic you
can wear the clothes you can see them in
the store they had hangar desirability
the Tatum guys I believe were very
representative of what the International
Woolmark price represents you know the
competition is about exploring
innovative ways of using wool and I
think that they did that beautifully the
designers developed a type of woollen
lace for their collection they applied
it to woolen fabric to create
three-dimensional patterns
we know and this idea helped tietam
Jones to beat more than 70 other
entrants in February and scooped the
65,000 euro prize in the category
womenswear
when you're young and you're passionate
in your creative you know these sort of
help along the way really helps you to
grow your brand so it's it's enormously
important back at the tetum Jones
workshop in London for Catherine Tatum
and Rob Jones the past few weeks have
been rather exceptional since winning
the international Woolmark prize they've
been catapulted into the international
fashion limelight it's very exciting at
the moment so it was it was good it was
good it was just it was us yet it was a
bit of a bang kind of when it happened
thank you always there's always some
kind of you need that retrospective time
to allow yourself to actually really
take in everything that's happening but
there's not actually a kind of clear
space of time we have not stopped so we
have gone to within New York we then we
came back and had five days to put on
our london fashion week show which kind
of regardless of the competition that's
a focus that was happening anyway and we
then go to Paris we just come back from
Paris we have traveled it's scheduled
out for the next 12 months
the two designers who are strictly
business partners met several years ago
in Italy while working for the fashion
house john richmond both wanted to
return home to London in 2010 they set
up their own label to achieve that goal
to match the standards of big luxury
labels they have everything produced in
Britain and thanks to a direct dialogue
with their suppliers they've been able
to do something very special despite the
labels small size we are inspired by
human stories and each season we find
that human story and it takes us on to
this kind of world where we build our
mood and inspiration and that is kind of
the starting point for us each season
for example the labels Woolmark
collection was inspired by an English
nun who set up a woolen mill in a small
Irish town at the end of the 19th
century she helped provide the
inhabitants with a livelihood this story
is reflected in the fabrics created by
the designers
our aesthetic is bold it's exquisite
it's modern and it's polished so every
textile that we do has to encompass that
visual aesthetic but it will be inspired
by the particular human story that we're
looking at caesars in addition to the
65,000 year of prize money tietam Jones
have also won new sales opportunities
some of the world's most prestigious
fashion retailers are going to stock
their collection including Saks Fifth
Avenue in New York Harvey Nichols in
London and my Teresa an online shop for
high-end fashion what's really exciting
at the moment is that we have this
global platform to show what we do and
we're really ready for it now and we're
going to kind of take it and run the
are you scared no no this is what we do
this is what we work for this is what we
dream about Catherine T demand Rob Jones
are two British designers who are going
places and thanks to the International
woolmark prize they're likely to reach
them even sooner